und ich rufe jetzt auf den
Tagesordnungspunkt 25 hier geht es um
die Beratung des Antrag Union des
Antrags der Unionsfraktion global
Gateway der Europäischen Union zu einem
Erfolg machen global Gateway ist eine
Initiative zur
Investitionen globale
Infrastrukturprojekte vor allen Dingen
Konkurrenz zu China und die Union möchte
dass da mehr verzahnt mit den
Initiativen der G7 Staaten wird also
zwischen der Europäischen Union
einerseits den 27 Staaten und den G7
Staaten andererseits also ganz besonders
mit den USA Kanada und Japan
im Moment ist noch etwas Unruhe im
Plenarsaal es wechselt sozusagen noch
einmal die Mannschaft das Thema global
Gateway wirtschaftsinvestition ist ja
auch etwas anders als Medienpolitik in
Sachen Deutsche Welle und erste Rednerin
des Katja leikert von der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion Mitglied im
Auswärtigen Ausschuss
Kollegen es ist mir wirklich eine sehr
große Freude heute unseren Antrag zu
global Gateway einzubringen und ich sage
Ihnen auch warum ich halte es für
absolut notwendig dass wir als
Europäerinnen und Europäer unseren Way
of Life verteidigen und uns aktiv und
selbstbewusst in der Systemkonkurrenz
gegenüber gerade China positionieren und
wir von der cdu/csu-fraktion haben uns
in den letzten Monaten immer wieder
gefragt liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
von der Ampel ob sie die Notwendigkeit
zu handeln auch endlich sehen und ich
muss wirklich sagen als ich am Montag
ins Handelsblatt geschaut habe war ich
das möchte ich mal sagen positiv
überrascht da bringen wir unseren Antrag
ein zu global Gateway in der letzten
Woche setzen wir Ihnen auf und zack
einige Tage vor der Debatte landet ein
Geheimpapier von ihnen dazu in der
Presse und endlich äußern sie sich hier
konkret und öffentlich und das ist
wirklich ein wichtiger Prozess und
vielleicht darf man das vor Weihnachten
auch einmal sagen das ist wirklich ein
vernünftiger und demokratischer Prozess
aber
Kolleginnen und Kollegen man darf auch
noch Wünsche haben vor Weihnachten bitte
beschleunigen und das meine ich sehr
ernsthaft beschleunigen Sie Ihre
Prozesse wenn es um das wichtige Feld
der Außen- und Sicherheitspolitik geht
das ist uns wirklich ein ganz großes
Anliegen
sie haben sich wenn man mal zurückblickt
wirklich Zeit gelassen schon vor über
einem Jahr hat die Europäische
Kommission die Initiative global Gateway
vorgestellt ziel ist es darin 300
Milliarden an öffentlichen und privaten
Eltern bereitzustellen und damit Europas
Rolle für globale Infrastruktur zu
stärken und das ist ein richtig guter
Plan von der Europäischen Union bisher
das muss ich hier niemanden groß
erklären dominiert China das fällt mit
der
seidenstraßeninitiative über eine
Billionen US-Dollar sind schon
investiert im Gegenzug sitzen dann
chinesische politkommissare in den
wichtigen Häfen zum Beispiel im
Dschibuti und diese Häfen werden dann
über Straßen die natürlich auch die
Chinesen gebaut haben mit Ressourcen aus
dem Hinterland versorgt kurz gesagt
china hat es bereits lange geschafft
Infrastruktur global zu denken und ganz
klare Vorteile für sich daraus dann auch
zu ziehen und wo liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen stehen wir in diesem Wettbewerb
im Sommer dieses Jahres haben wir dazu
wie sich für die Opposition gehört eine
kleine Anfrage gestellt zu diesem Thema
wir hatten sie unter anderem nach
konkreten Projekten gefragt die die
Bundesregierung im Rahmen von Global
Gateway unterstützen würde wir hatten
gefragt welche Projekte sie aktiv
einbringen wollen und Ihre Antwort
darauf war damals sie können es
nachlesen wirklich nichts es gab leere
Phrasen es gab verweise aus
Gesprächsrunden aber wirklich konkrete
Projekte oder eigene Initiativen
komplette Fehlanzeige aber dafür gibt es
ja auch uns und immerhin sie scheinen
daraus und dass die frohe Botschaft vor
Weihnachten gelernt zu haben nachdem wir
diese kleine Anfrage gestellt hatten und
diese plenarber Debatte nachgeschoben
haben bewegt sich endlich etwas es gibt
endlich konkrete Vorschläge das finden
wir gut
und es gibt auch einen Fokus auf
Leuchtturmprojekte damit zum Schluss
nicht nur die zwei drei Kilometer
chinesische Autobahn immer im
Vordergrund stehen und da kann man zum
Jahreswechsel feststellen der Druck aus
der Opposition wirkt
doch liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
eine Schwalbe oder ein Artikel im
Handelsblatt macht natürlich noch kein
Frühling wir werden Versprechen an dem
Thema dran zu bleiben uns ist das sehr
sehr wichtig bitte machen sie auch
entsprechend Druck in Brüssel und setzen
Sie die Projekte die sie jetzt
angekündigt haben um in diesem Sinne
frohe Weihnachten
soweit könnt ihr like hat von der
Unionsfraktion die auch darauf
hingewiesen hat dass es ja ein großes
Konkurrenzunternehmen gibt nämlich von
China das mehrere 100 Milliarden Euro
investiert in das Seitenstraße Projekt
und da will man jetzt der gegenhalten
nächste Rednerin ist nicht der stand
noch von der SPD aus dem Ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung
die hier ganz rechts sitzt deshalb freue
ich mich heute umso mehr dass wir
zusammen eine EU-Initiative debattieren
bei der wir den Ansatz alle Mal
gemeinsam hier loben können denn glaube
Gateway steht ja im Grundsatz für etwas
was uns allen bewusst ist wenn wir mal
ganz ehrlich sind wenn wir alle zusammen
für unsere europäischen Interessen
eintreten haben wir Gewichte in der Welt
und wenn wir das alle nur unsere mit
unserem eigenen Süppchen kochen und
schwimmen dann eben nicht und wir sehen
seit einiger Zeit wie beispielsweise
China und das hat die Kollegin hier auch
gerade schon gesagt massiv in den
Ländern des globalen Südens unterwegs
ist und seine geopolitischen und in
seine geopolitischen Interessen
investiert dabei wird den Ländern jedoch
nicht auf Augenhöhe begegnet ganz im
Gegenteil sie werden in schädliche
Abhängigkeiten gedrängt und ihrer
Ressourcen beraubt Menschenrechte und
entwicklungspolitische Grundsätze werden
dabei völlig übergangen in ihrem Antrag
schreiben Sie und den Satz will ich hier
oben hervorheben man solle den
Partnerländern die Vorteile einer
Kooperation mit liberalen Demokratien
auf
aber was bedeutet das dann konkret für
mich bedeutet das ein respektvollen
Umgang für unsere Partnerin oder mit
unseren Partnerinnen und Partnern vor
Ort in den Ländern des globalen Südens
eben auf Augenhöhe und im Miteinander zu
finden wir müssen die Bedürfnisse die
vor Ort geäußert werden berücksichtigten
und dann gemeinsam nachhaltige Ideen
umsetzen wenn ich mir jetzt aber ihren
Antrag anschaue dann ist da viel von
Investitionsmöglichkeiten und
Abmilderung von Investitionsrisiken für
deutsche Unternehmen zu lesen aber es
geht doch hier nicht um die deutsche
Wirtschaft zu allererst darum wie sie
angekurbelt werden kann und wie man neue
Absatzmärkte erschließen kann es sind
doch gerade die kolonialen
Abhängigkeiten die wirtschaftliche
Ausbeutung in vielen Ländern des
globalen Südens überhaupt erst oder die
Länder des globalen Südens überhaupt
erst in dieser Abhängigkeiten gebracht
haben das müssen wir doch jetzt bitte
nicht noch mit einem europäischen Update
versehen es geht um partnerschaftliche
Zusammenarbeit die in beiderseitigen
Interesse ist es geht darum die
Verbindung zwischen EU und den
Partnerländern zu vertiefen und es geht
darum den Einfluss autoritärer Regime
zurückzudringen
und mir fehlt da vor allen Dingen ein
Aspekt Liebe Union der im vorliegenden
Antrag wurde ja vor allen Dingen unter
der Federführung ihrer
entwicklungspolitiker verfasst was ist
denn eigentlich mit den STGs haben sie
die vergessen oder waren die ihn einfach
zu unwichtig um sie zu erwähnen ich als
entwicklungspolitikerin finde jedenfalls
dass bei Global Gateway die sdgs in den
fünf definierten Bereichen digitales
Klima und Energie Transport Gesundheit
sowie Bildung und Forschung immer mit
bedacht werden müssen
die EU-Kommission hat ihrerseits schon
im Dezember 2021 versichert das glaube
Gateway vollständig die Agenda 2030 und
auch auf das Klimaabkommen von Paris
abgestimmt ist darauf müssen wir auch
weiter beharren das ist klar der
Bundesregierung und insbesondere
Bundesministerin Schulze ist es sehr
sehr bewusst gemeinsam als
Ampelkoalition setzen wir uns für eine
zügige Umsetzung von Global Gateway ein
und tatsächlich geht es bei Global
Gateway ja bereits voran die ersten fünf
Leuchtturmprojekte in Zentralasien
Lateinamerika und Afrika wurden in
diesem September schon angekündigt die
Bundesregierung bringt sich aktiv ein
und arbeitet zusammen mit unseren
Partnerinnen und Partnern in der EU
daran das glaube Gateway ein gemeinsamer
Erfolg wird
mir persönlich ist es aber auch wichtig
dass die EU-Kommission transparent
agiert was die glaube
gateway-initiativen angeht den
aspekttransparenz vermisse ich übrigens
auch in ihrem Antrag glaube Gateway
Initiativen sollten eben nicht nur
zwischen Rat und Kommission beschlossen
werden das Europäische Parlament muss
hier mit einbezogen werden eine
parlamentarische Kontrolle ist wichtig
wenn die EU gegenüber Partnerstaaten die
Vorzüge von Zusammenarbeit mit
Demokratien glaubhaft vermitteln möchte
ich bin sicher die Bundesregierung wird
sich dafür einsetzen das glaube Geld bei
einer Erfolg wird so wie die EU geht
strategisch wird die eu-strategisch
gestärkt und gleichzeitig wird eine
damit verbundene
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit auf Augenhöhe
und zum Nutzen unserer Partnerländer und
der Menschen vor Ort umgesetzt ich danke
Ihnen für Ihre Vorschläge für den aus
dem Antrag den wir aus der genannten
Gründen auch ablehnen werden aber ich
hoffe dass wir weiter genauso wie Sie
uns auffordern sich auch bei der EU
stark zu machen dass sie sich auch stark
machen denn ich glaube sie haben dann
ganz guten Draht gerade zur
Kommissionspräsidenten und ich hoffe
dass Ihnen auch weiterhin gut nutzen
werden danke schön
insgesamt
568 Milliarden Euro sollen da
ausgewendet werden für diese Initiative
global Gateway die EU gemeinsam vor
allem mit den USA und Japan in
Konkurrenz zu China um eben die Vorteile
einer Kooperation mit liberalen
Demokratien zu zeigen für die
sogenannten Partnerländer des Südens
Harald weil von der AFD ist der nächste
Redner
frau Präsidentin sehr geehrtes
vorweihnachtliches Publikum es wurden ja
hier jetzt schon Sachen gesagt die da
gar nicht im Antrag drin stehen und von
wegen die deutsche Wirtschaft
numero 16 Forderung Nummer 16 da geht's
um die Förderung Projektausschreibung
für die mittelständische Unternehmen und
dass die CDU CSU damit deutsche
Unternehmen gemeint haben könnte das
muss doch sehr muss dann noch mal
bestätigt werden noch mal extra steht
auf jeden Fall nichts davon drin dafür
ist aber ein Punkt 11 das bei Global
Gateway auch genügend Mittel für Mädchen
Strategie und Öffentlichkeitsarbeit
bereitstellen die welche missratenen
Projekte auch immer im Nachhinein
offenbar schön reden sollen so wie der
Anteil von Öffentlichkeitsarbeit im
Budget der Europäischen Union und was
geht es denn eigentlich ja also zwischen
2000 und 2018 haben afrikanische Staaten
allein 150 Milliarden Dollar Schulden
bei China aufgenommen es hat also schon
vor der Welt Android Initiative 13
erheblich Investitionen gegeben und
China verfolgt diesen Ansatz auch in
Asien Europa Lateinamerika und im
Pazifik Stand Juli 2020 standen die
afrikanischen Ländern Durchschnitt mit
22 Prozent bei China in der Kreide und
als weitere Hauptgläubiger kommen dann
auch schon die Weltbank und der IWF die
multilateralen regionalen
Entwicklungsbanken und schließlich
Einzelstaaten und Privatinstitute man
fragt sich jetzt erstmal was machen die
eigentlich was macht die Asiatische
Entwicklungsbank was macht die
europäische Entwicklung Entwicklungsbank
für Osteuropa was macht die afrikanische
Entwicklung muss man etc sie sehen hier
das ist hochgradig redundant welcher
Praktikanten Brainstorm hat dieses
Papier gezeugt es ist eine einzige
Redundanz es gibt die Gelder es gibt die
Initiativen anderer Leute es gibt
aber dutzende eigene Institution auch im
EU-Rahmen auch im internationalsten
Rahmen wieso machen sie den deutschen
Einfluss nicht in diesen Gremien von
Weltbank über IWF Entwicklungsbanken er
geltend vielleicht sogar so dass auch
deutsche Unternehmen sogar
mittelständische Unternehmen was davon
haben da ist nichts daran zu finden bei
Ihnen
so nun will nachweislich die
nachweislich auch zu Hause schon nicht
besonders lernfähige EU noch mal 300
Milliarden von 20 20 bis 27 nach Afrika
die Hälfte davon nach Afrika transferien
sag ich mal ja 150 Milliarden sieht auch
hier das sind die Chinesen gepackgeber
müssen 150 Milliarden entgegensetzen die
Amerikaner machen so was ähnliches die
Japaner machen sowas ähnliches ich
glaube sogar Luxemburg und Liechtenstein
waren auch sowas ähnlich das ist ein
klassische metho-geschichte und mangelt
jede Kreativität noch jede Hinweis auf
eine Lernkurve investieren kann man da
vieles gar nicht nennen es eher eine
zusätzliche
fehlinvestitionsrampe zusätzlich zu
allem UNO gemacht mache und rund um den
Dauerbrenner Entwicklungshilfe Krämer
Religion Pariser Übereinkommen und
untaugliche erneuerbare rettungsprojekte
Beispiel die Schwierigkeiten die eine
Regierung oder Bevölkerung ins Sri Lanka
hat hat diesen nicht weil Chinesen dort
den Hafenbau erfolgreich betreiben
sozusagen im Altenglischen Stil mit 99
Jahren Pachtzeit und Kreditbesicherung
etc sondern Schwierigkeiten hat Sri
Lanka weil es unter einem auf Brüsseler
spitzenberatung gesetzt hat ja und seine
Landwirtschaft und Energiepolitik auf
Klima und ökodogmatik umstellte mit der
Folge von ertragseinbrüchen und
Ernährungskrise und stets gesteigerter
erneuerbarer Verschuldungsproblematik
der Suizid Hegemonialmacht EU aber will
sich der die will sich zum Global Player
aufspielen mit dieser metopolitik bei
Dingen diese nicht mal regional schaffen
ein global propans nenne ich das doch
eher
allein in Osteuropa schafft man das
nicht im eigenen Vorhof auch auf dem
Balkan nicht da können und wurden keine
Dinge positiv beeinflusst nicht von
Deutschland nicht von der EU alles zu
little to late und auch nur im Gefolge
andere Leute so und international wird
westlicherseits ja bereits jährlich
nicht über 5 Jahreszeitraum jährlich 150
Milliarden Dollar in die
Entwicklungsgeschichte gepumpt sie
kommen zum Ende bitte seit 2015 noch mal
CC CO2 Planwirtschaft Pariser Abkommen
das sind auch noch mal 100 Milliarden
Sie konsumente bitte die 200 Teilnehmer
freuen sich über zusehes Geld so und von
diesem Herr und Kollegen ich komme zum
Ehren Redezeit war bereits eine weiteren
geldschleuder wie viel mehr her sondern
die Kollegen das was bereits da ist
zurückgreifen steht
ordnen sie ein und ich wünsche allen
einen vorgelaufen Umkehr gewesen
sein ist
bereits seit längerer Zeit abgelaufen
ich muss Ihnen sonst ich muss jeden
Sonntag das Mikrofon komplett abstellen
und bitte Sie jetzt das Polizei zu
verlassen haben ich bitte Sie das cool
zu verlassen Herr Kollege
ja soweit am Ende musste dann wohl sagen
der Auftritt von Harald weil vom von der
afd-bundestagsfraktion nächste Rednerin
Katrin Henneberger von der
bündnisgrundfraktion zum Thema global
Gateway Investitionen in
Infrastrukturprojekte
die Entwicklung Zusammenarbeit auf
partnerschaftliche Augenhöhe im
Vordergrund stehen das sind unsere
Leitlinien die Leitlinien der
Bundesregierung leider finde ich diese
nicht im Antrag der CDU im Antrag der
Union wird nicht eingefordert die
Einhaltung von Menschenrechten von
indigenrechten den systemable der Welles
oder dem Paris agreement eine eigene
eine Ausrichtung bei der Umsetzung der
Vorhaben auf feministische
Entwicklungspolitik wird ebenfalls nicht
beachtet deshalb ist der Antrag leider
in der Vergangenheit stecken geblieben
und verpasst die Chance zu zeigen dass
auch die Union die Wichtigkeit von
Gender sensibler Investition ernst nimmt
global Gateway soll aktuelle finanzielle
Lücken für die Umsetzung von
Entwicklungszielen schließen ein Problem
ist jedoch dass dadurch oft nur
Investitionen in bereits stärkere
Wirtschaftsregionen getätigt werden
wodurch die Länder die Unterstützung am
nötigsten haben wenig bis gar nicht
davon profitieren außerdem besteht die
Gefahr dass man im Bereich Bildung und
Gesundheitsvorsorge besonders auf
private Investition setzt öffentliche
Einrichtungen privatisiert und teurer
dadurch werden und somit nicht mehr für
alle Teile der Bevölkerung zugänglich
sind deshalb ist es wichtig dass
Investitionen immer im Einklang stehen
mit den Zielen für nachhaltige
Entwicklung und das Ziel haben ein gutes
Leben für alle Bevölkerungsgruppen zu
ermöglichen
also
so soll die Initiative auch Transport
und Infrastrukturprojekte finanzieren
wie beispielsweise Autobahnausbau in
Kenia und Liberia Ziel muss für uns aber
sein nicht nur unsere industrielle und
überwiegend autofreundliche
Infrastruktur in andere Länder zu
transportieren sondern
mobilitätsunterstützen welche den
Menschen vor Ort nützt
die gemeinwohlorientiert aufgestellt ist
außerdem Klima und Umweltschutz
einbezieht Mobilität ist eine integrale
Aufgabe von Stadt und Raumplanung und
auch hier ist es eine feministische
mobilitätspolitik die den Weg ebnet um
den Bedürfnissen aller Menschen gerecht
zu werden
damit die Initiativen keine neokoladen
Beigeschmack bekommt ist es wichtig auf
eine gleichberechtigte Partnerschaft mit
den Ländern zu setzen zu dem muss
Transparenz bei der Auswahl der Projekte
hergestellt werden sowie bei der
Überwachung von Menschenrechten
Umweltschutz und Klimaschutz außerdem
muss eine Konsultation mit der lokalen
Bevölkerung erfolgen diese Punkte werden
im jungsantrag nicht ausreichend
behandelt sie sind aber grundlage
unserer Arbeit vielen Dank
soweit Katrin Henneberger von den
Bündnis Grünen in der laufenden Debatte
und nächster Redner ist Alexander Ulrich
von der Fraktion DIE LINKE Kolleginnen
und Kollegen vor rund einem Jahr hat die
Europäische Kommission dieses Programm
vorgestellt und wenn man jetzt nach
einem Jahr
ein erstes Zwischenfazit setzen will
muss man schon sagen es ist kaum was
passiert und das ja nicht nur ein
Problem der deutschen Bundesregierung
ist ein Problem auch der anderen
EU-Länder was darauf zurückschließen
lässt dass die Europäische Kommission
auch ein Programm offensichtlich
vorgestellt hat dass nicht schon
abgedatet war mit den Mitgliedsländern
und das ist auch schwer jetzt
nachzuholen den Täuschung ist schon
riesengroß dass da kaum was passiert und
man kann ja auch wirklich feststellen
außer große Sprüche dass man auch eine
riesen Summe ins Schaufenster stellt ist
noch nichts passiert und mit dieser
Geschwindigkeit werden wir das was
andere Länder tun China oder auch die
USA nicht begegnen können und ihn so
weit muss ich schon sagen ist gut dass
die Union diesen Antrag auch hier
einbringt ob jetzt das Geheimpapier das
an die Öffentlichkeit geraten ist mit
diesem Antrag zu tun hat bezweiflich war
aber dass man sich zumindest mal der
Bundesregierung so langsam mal auf den
Weg macht das ein oder andere zu
diskutieren ist schon mal
ein guter Schritt aber Frau leik hat das
kann ich jetzt schon sagen es geht bei
Global Gateway nicht darum einfach nur
geopolitische
Strategien zu verfolgen gegen China es
kann auch nicht darum gehen gegen die
USA sondern wenn wir das Thema Erfolg
führen wollen wenn wir die soziale
ökologisch Transformation auch im
globalen Süden voranbringen wollen dann
geht es nur in Win-Win-Situation dass
auch diese Länder nicht das Gefühl haben
ausgebeutet zu werden dass auch diese
Länder im Prinzip
Entwicklungsfortschritte haben und das
was sie in ihrem Papier beschreiben ist
doch sonst nichts das ihn darum geht
wirtschaftlichen Interessen der
deutschen Industrie zu vertreten und
darum geht's gerade nicht in diesem
global Gateway wir werden das nicht so
beantworten können und ganz nebenbei
glaube ich auch nicht dass es gut
ankommt bei diesen Partnerländern wenn
wenn wenn man immer nur gesagt bekommt
wir brauchen eine europäische Antwort
auf die Leute neue Seitenstraße
Initiative noch einmal diese Länder
Fragen nicht danach ob wir eine liberale
Demokratie sind und ob die Chinesen was
anderes haben die Fragen danach wer kann
uns unterstützen wer will mit uns
partnerschaftlich zusammenarbeiten und
tut mir leid dass Sie die Chinesen
scheinbar ein bisschen schneller und in
dieser Woche hat hat es ein Gipfel
gegeben von den USA mit afrikanischen
Ländern auch da passiert mehr wie eine
Europäischen Union also insoweit glaube
ich sind wir viel zu langsam unterwegs
und müssen da auch das ein oder andere
noch nachholen
im September gab es eine Studie von Euro
dat und auch da wurde gesagt dass es
geht hauptsächlich um private
Investitionen zu erleichtern und
europäische Wirtschaft Interessen wenn
das das Hauptziel von Global Gateway ist
dann wird dieses diese Instrument
scheitern dann werden wir keine großen
Fortschritte machen deshalb die Linke
sagt ja zum sozialökologischen Umbau
auch des globalen Südens dass wir eine
Verantwortung haben als Europäische
Union auch als deutsche Bundesregierung
damit zu machen aber es geht nur
partnerschaftlich auf Augenhöhe und
nicht dass wir den Eindruck hinterlassen
wir wollen diese Länder nur Ausbeuten
vielen Dank
ja soweit Alexander Ulrich von den
Linken darauf hingewiesen dass es
natürlich auch darum geht dass die
Partnerländer im Süden auf Augenhöhe der
Europäischen Union Link in sieben
Staaten gegenüber stehen nächster Redner
dillmannsmann von der FDP
und er ist dort
politische Sprecher
13 Billionen Euro 13
000 Milliarden Euro bis 2040 die wir
global investieren müssen wenn uns die
Transformation gelingen soll daran
möchte auch muss auch die Europäische
Union mitwirken und das machen wir und
deswegen sind ganz viele Punkte die sie
in ihrem Antrag haben richtig dabei sag
ihm gib und Glas sie tragen da Eulen
nach Athen sie fordern da viele Sachen
an den wir längst dran sind und ich
beginne mal zum Beispiel mit der
Forderung nach nach mehr
internationalen Wirtschaftsabkommen wir
haben gerade ceta verabschiedet wir sind
in konstruktiven Gesprächen mit Merkur
und dass wir in Amerika mit den
Vereinigten Staaten gerade im Moment
schwierige Diskussionen haben das liegt
nicht nur an uns das liegt natürlich
auch an der Struktur des Inflation
reduction Act die etwas problematisch
ist aber auch da sind wir jetzt in
Gesprächen drin und das ist alles das
was sie in den letzten 16 Jahren nicht
hinbekommen haben es sind aber auch
andere Sachen die die durchaus richtig
und wichtig sind sie sprechen auch von
Rohstoffen das unterstreichen wir
unterstreichen unterstreichen wir ganz
eindeutig das ist gut so aber um was
geht es eigentlich im Wesentlichen es
geht darum nicht nur dass wir
geostrategisch uns Aufstellen im
Vergleich zu den autoritären Regime
sondern es geht eben auch darum die
Klimaziele global einzuhalten es geht
also darum dass Energiesystem der Welt
umzustellen und was macht was macht
erneuerbare Energien transportabel und
was macht sie speicherbar das ist
Wasserstoff und sie legen uns einen
Antrag vor auf drei Seiten mit 19
Punkten kein einziges Mal das Wort
Wasserstoff auftaucht
da steht aber nicht Wasserstoff drin das
sind drei Wasserstoff Derivate genannt
oder
ja ja es ist schon erstaunlich einfach
weil es einfach das Zentrum haben sich
erfasst und das wundert sich jetzt nicht
dass ich als innovationsbeauftragter für
grünen Wasserstoff im Bundesministerium
für Bildung und Forschung diesen Punkt
hier mal ganz kurz erwähnen ich bin
übrigens auch froh dass eine Sache in
ihrem Antrag nicht drin steht und das
ist das was in den letzten
Legislaturperiode meiner Ansicht nach
die ganze Zeit ein wenig problematisch
gemacht haben nämlich die ganze Zeit die
Verbindung mit Migration in einer etwas
schiefenform das ist jetzt raus das ist
weitgehend raus das ist jetzt viel
vernünftiger da haben sie auch dazu
gelernt und deswegen im Großen und
Ganzen das ist ein interessanter Antrag
in dem wir über den wir ihm einen
Ausschuss sehr gerne intensiv noch mal
diskutieren aber ich möchte mal einfach
zusammenfassen und was geht's im
Wesentlichen in dem was wir uns
gemeinsam vorgenommen haben und da
möchte ich ähm unsere Außenministerin an
der Lena bärburg zitieren weil man
manchmal ja richtige Sachen vor allen
Dingen ganz unaufgeregt formulieren kann
sie hat gesagt im System wird Bewerb
genügt es nicht gute Argumente für
unsere liberale demokratisches Modell zu
haben wir müssen andere Ländern auch
zeigen dass wir als EU bessere Angebote
machen können und zwar transparent auf
Augenhöhe ohne Knebelverträge und genau
das werden wir tun vielen Dank
so tillmannsmann von der FDP war das
nächste Redner Tobias Winkler von der
unionsfraktionausschuss für
Angelegenheiten der Europäischen Union
es geht ja vor allen Dingen auch eine um
eine europäische Initiative von seiner
Fraktion hier noch einmal in einem
Antrag verstärkt der Antrag glaube
Gateway zu einem Erfolg machen ist ein
guter Antrag und ich glaube auch die
Kollegen von der FDP herrmannsmann sie
müssen es zugeben alles was da drin
steht kann man so stehen lassen wir
hätten den heute direkt beschließen
können wenn sie sagen Wasserstoff fehlt
ihnen da drin das haben wir glaube ich
gerade schon ausgeräumt dass es sogar
drin ist wir haben nicht die global
Gateway Strategie da drin formuliert
sondern uns geht's darum dass das was in
Brüssel beschlossen ist jetzt auch zur
Umsetzung kommt zügig zu Umsetzung kommt
und das ist das ist die Forderung und
das ist der Kern dieses Antrags sonst
würden sie noch viel mehr finden was sie
da vielleicht vermissen ich möchte auch
darauf hinweisen dass ein Erfolg dieses
global Gateways weit mehr ist als ein
wirtschaftlicher Erfolg weit mehr als
dies das Sichern deutscher Interessen
ich glaube Frau Henneberger hat es
gesagt deutsche industrieinteressen
dabei geht es um unsere Lebensmodell das
so wie es Katja leikert formuliert hat
das europäische Lebensmodell das was uns
unterscheidet eben von anderen
Wettbewerbern oder in dem Fall Rivalen
wie China oder virusland die wie schon
dargestellt das in aller Welt versuchen
zu exportieren und herr Ulrich es ist
nicht so dass die die Länder die
Verträge mit China eingehen das machen
weil sie schneller sind oder sie nicht
darauf schauen was dahinter ist sondern
sie haben kein anderes Angebot das ist
es sie werden in diese Lage gezwungen
und deshalb ist es für uns wichtig dass
Europäische Union ein attraktives
Angebot zu machen für diese Länder um
sich entwickeln zu können
und dass wir hier zusammenarbeiten
müssen da muss ich sagen verwunderts
mich dann schon dass wenn der
Wirtschaftsminister nach Namibia reist
und dort über auch grüne Energie über
grünen Wasserstoff spricht mit keinem
einzigen Wort weder in der
Pressemitteilung noch während seines
Besuchs über global Gateway spricht und
auf der anderen Seite die zuständige
Kommissarin aber sagt grüner Wasserstoff
in Namibia ist ein Leuchtturmprojekt des
Global Gateway also hier passt nicht
zusammen das sind sogar zwei grüne
Ministerien die sich glaube ich noch
etwas besser absprechen müssen wenn wir
global Gateway ernst nehmen dann müssen
wir zusammenarbeiten als Deutsche als
deutsche Regierung gemeinsam mit der
Europäischen Kommission als Team Europe
und so Auftreten in der Welt dass man
dort auch versteht das ist eine
europäische Initiative
und Glaube Gateway gibt auch die Chance
Vertrauen zurückzugewinnen vertrauen
dass wir bei unseren europäischen
Partnern verloren haben in
beeindruckender Weise innerhalb eines
Jahres ob das im Osten ist ob das im
Westen ist bei den kleineren Ländern da
waren wir früher ein Garant in Europa
dieses Vertrauen ist massiv beschädigt
worden und jetzt können wir zeigen dass
wir zusammenarbeiten in diese Initiative
und dieses verloren gegangene Vertrauen
wiedergewinnen wollen
ich glaube Gateway ist nicht nur ein
Instrument für die Länder für die
Menschen vor Ort um ihnen besseres Leben
zu ermöglichen ist nicht nur ein
Instrument um die europäische Wirtschaft
in der Welt ausbreiten zu können ich
glaube Gateway ist auch ein Projekt um
verloren gegangen ist Vertrauen
zurückzugewinnen dafür setzen wir uns
einen dafür hoffen wir bei der
Bundesregierung auch gehört zu finden
und die entsprechende Unterstützung
herzlichen Dank auch dass noch so viele
Kollegen um diese Uhrzeit zu hören danke
schön
ja global Gateway die EU-Kommission hat
ja gesagt man möchte kein Land abhängig
machen von der Union wenn man eine halbe
Billion Euro in diese Länder jetzt
investiert anders als China das Jahr
Länder von sich abhängig macht indem es
sie unterstützt nächster Redner Jörg
Nürnberger von der SPD-Fraktion am
Mittwoch dieser Woche haben wir hier im
Bundestag mit Zustimmung der
cdu/csu-fraktion einen von uns
eingebrachten Antrag zu Unterstützung
der Republik Moldau beschlossen das war
eine gute Entscheidung das Beispiel der
Republik Moldau eines kleinen
osteuropäischen landeszeit ganz
eindrücklich worum es auch beim global
Gateway gehen muss wir müssen starten
und Gesellschaften auf Augenhöhe
Entwicklungsmöglichkeiten geben diese
auf Ihrem Weg zu schaffen oder zur
Stabilisierung an der freiheitlichen
Demokratie unterstützen
seit dem Zerfall der Sowjetunion
schwankt die Republik Moldau zwischen
einer Ausrichtung auf Russland oder dem
Weg zu einer westlichen Demokratie
angesichts des Kriegs im Nachbarland
Ukraine hat sich mal dafür unseren Weg
entschieden wir unterstützen Maler
bereits heute dabei was in Europa für
Länder wie Moldau die Ukraine Georgien
oder den westbalkern gilt gilt umso mehr
für die Staaten Lateinamerikas Afrikas
und Asiens autoritär geführte Staaten
wie China und Russland versuchen sich in
den genannten Ländern langfristig
Einfluss zu verschaffen china hat und
das Projekt wurde öfters erwähnt mit der
neuen Seitenstraße bereits Fakten
geschaffen die der Westen nicht
ignorieren darf unsere gemeinsame
Antwort darauf lautet die Initiative
global Gateway
der Antrag der cdu/csu hält diesen
Konsens zwischen den demokratischen
Parteien hier im aus richtig fest
allerdings klingt doch an manchen
Stellen dem Antrag durch dass sich die
cdu/csu-fraktion sehr auf bestimmte
Interessen ihr nahestehender Gruppen
wieder Wirtschaftsverbände fokussiert
wenn hier der Staat sehr erheblichen
Teilen für Investitionsrisiken haften
soll und zum Beispiel der Antrag
gleichzeitig gar kein einziges Wort
darüber verliert dass bei solchen
Investitionen auch die Rechte von
ArbeitnehmerInnen gewahrt werden müssen
als bayerischer Abgeordneter erlaube ich
mir noch eine Anmerkung zum Punkt 12 der
enthält nämlich die Formulierung das
gezielt auf öffentlich wirksame
Leuchtturmprojekte gesetzt werden muss
dann spricht einiges für die Vermutung
dass der Autor dieses Punktes enge
Verbindungen zum Bayerischen
Staatskanzlei hat wir haben nämlich in
Bayern in der Landesentwicklung in den
letzten Jahren trotz der 10h-regelung
bereits eine derart unübersichtliche
Anzahl von Leuchttürmen gebaut dass man
in Bayern eigentlich noch mehr sehen
bräuchte um die ganzen Leuchttürme
unterzubringen
[Applaus]
das Leuchttürme während es sinnvoller
gewesen es geht nämlich auch bei der
Initiative global Gateway nicht um
Symbolik sondern um Vernetzung und
Nachhaltigkeit hierin besteht der
Mehrwert für unsere Partnerstadt und
außerhalb der EU dem trägt der Antrag
der cdu/csu nicht ausreichend Rechnung
es besteht Beratungsbedarf wir als
Sozialdemokratinnen oder Teil der
Ampelkoalition wünschen uns auch mehr
Tempo von der EU-Kommission bei der
Umsetzung
wir werden in jedem Fall alles daran
setzen dass diese Initiative ein Erfolg
wird und unterstützen daher die
Bundesregierung bei ihrer Arbeit mit der
Kommission um die ersten bereits
ausgewählten konkreten Projekte zu
verwirklichen in allen frohe
Weihnachtstage und vielen Dank für die
Aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
Georg Nürnberger von der SPD aus dem
Wahlkreis Hof kann Bayern ganz oben
darauf hat er jetzt gerade noch mal
hingewiesen der nächste Redner stand
ebenfalls aus Bayern hat Deutschland
Wahlkreis Anton Hofreiter von Bündnis 90
die Grünen und Kollegen ich glaube das
Beste was mir über den Antrag sagen kann
ist dass sie eine Gelegenheit es über
das wichtige Thema glaube ich Gateway
der Europäischen Union zu sprechen sonst
wenn sie sich den Antrag noch mal
anschauen wird halt manches doch arg aus
der Zeit gefallen ich glaube so nicht
ganz unwichtige Dinge wie Klimaschutz
kommen bei ihnen gar nicht vor aber das
wie gesagt kann ja alles noch besser
werden was allerdings entscheidende
Punkt ist dass die Europäische Union
endlich eine solche Strategie hat denn
wir haben über viele Jahre zu lange
gewartet als Europäer haben zum Teil mit
großen Augen zugeschaut was China
weltweit treibt und haben selbst Ländern
bei uns in der Nachbarschaft wie
Montenegro
überlassen sich in die Schuldenfalle
durch China zu begeben und jetzt braucht
es dringend eine Alternative dazu und
diese Alternative ist global Gateway und
deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass die
EU-Kommission des auf den Weg gebracht
hat
und wenn dann davon die Rede ist dass es
ein Geheimpapier der Bundesregierung
gibt man kann ja durchaus machen was
kritisches zur Bundesregierung sagen
aber das ist kein Geheimpapier sondern
die Bundesregierung macht einfach
schlichtig ihren Job und hat deshalb
gegenüber der EU-Kommission das gemacht
was Exekutive macht in dem Zusammenhang
nicht klar gemacht dass Artikel der
Bundesregierung Projekte sind die
schnell umzusetzen sind die man jetzt
angehen muss und die die EU-Kommission
jetzt angehen sollte mit deutscher
Unterstützung das ist das so gegen die
Geheimpapier und das ist das was man von
der Bundesregierung die verstanden hat
dass China ein systemischer Rivale ist
erwarten kann und deshalb kann man das
einfach nur loben dass das zum Glück
passiert ist
und
und dann wenn man auf die EU-Kommission
blickt da muss man allerdings schon
sagen da muss deutlich mehr passieren
nämlich das Konzept des gut die
EU-Kommission gibt sich auch Mühe aber
sie ist halt ganz arg zerstritten in
ihrer eigenen Bürokratie nämlich auf der
einen Seite versucht die
Entwicklungsabteilung der EU-Kommission
das ganze allein für sich zu reklamieren
die Präsidenten möchte dass es eine
geostrategische Komponente bekommt und
so geht halt viel zu wenig voran und
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir vom
Parlament aus Druck machen ja es ist
wichtig dass es entwicklungspolitisch
sauber läuft aber es ist auch wichtig
dass wir die geopolitische Komponente
erkennen die dahinter steckt nämlich
china hat viel zu viele Länder in seine
Abhängigkeit gebracht und es ist halt de
facto eine Diktatur geworden und deshalb
müssen wir diesen Ländern von
demokratischen seit der ein Angebot
machen die haben jetzt gesehen in der
Auseinandersetzung um den Ukraine Krieg
wie viele Länder unsicher sind auf
welcher Seite sie sich positionieren
sollten und all diesen Ländern müssen
wir ein vernünftiges Angebot machen das
kann global Gateway sein und da müssen
wir noch deutlich mehr tun das ist das
am Ende dann auch wird vielen Dank
soweit Anton Hofreiter diese 568
Milliarden Euro die ich vorhin erwähnt
habe wieder insgesamt im Spiel sind
Europa USA Japan die sind allerdings im
kleinen Teil staatliche Hilfen zum
größeren Teil sind das
Kreditversicherungen für die in privaten
Investitionen nächste Redner krankmüller
Rosentritt FDP Gesellschaft schon
automatisch irgendwie die Geschichte auf
ihrer Seite haben werden durch das
Regierungshandeln der Kommunistischen
Partei China seit Jahren eines Besseren
belehrt der größte Verein der offenen
Gesellschaft ist in diesen Tagen die
Kommunistische Partei China ist nicht
nur für die Gesellschaft selbst sondern
auch für zahlreiche Länder auf der Welt
denen die Komponisten und dem Deckmantel
der chinesischen Weisheit auf charmante
Art den Eis diesem Atem du Unfreiheit
einhauchen mit der Belt Android
Initiative pinkes wichtigsten Projekt
schafft China seit mehr als zehn Jahren
in 140 Ländern ein System von
Abhängigkeiten getreute
seit Jahren tatsachen schafft blieb
unsere Antworten haben alle recht hier
viel zu lange viel zu wage wären wir
noch über die richtige Balance zwischen
den dreidimensionen Partner systemisch
verwaler oder wirtschaftlicher
Konkurrenz diskutieren hat die KPC diese
Frage schon vor Jahren beantwortet für
sie geht die größte Bedrohung von der
offenen Gesellschaft des globalen
Westens aus auf mein Reisen in den Asien
starten ist die am meisten gestellte
Frage an mich wo ist Deutschland wir
wollen nicht auf China angewiesen sein
wie können wir mit Deutschland Europa
mehr zusammenarbeiten das zeigt der
eindrucksvoll dass die Länder ganz stark
auf den starkes an Deutschlands unter
die eu-wappen unserer Partner brauchen
verlässlich Alternativen zur schieß
ausbeuterischerei deshalb ist es absolut
richtig dass die EU mit ihrem Programm
unserem Partner eine demokratische und
vor allem rechtsstaatliche Alternative
anbieten während allerdings China bis
2027 weltweit
1,3 Billionen Dollar für die Belohnung
ausgeben will planen wir nicht mal
Viertel davon doch neben dem dringend
nur durch den mehrkälte für Gateway
braucht es vor allem und das gebe ich
euch 100% recht viel mehr
Geschwindigkeit so unendlich Fahrt
aufgenommen werden deshalb war das
richtig und wichtig dass die
Bundesregierung nun konkrete
visionsvorschläge an die Kommission
gemacht hat nun muss es die Kommission
aber eben auch liefern da habt ihr
herausragende Kontakte über das Lindner
wir brauchen ein extremes Feuerwerk der
Diplomatie in den Asia Ländern in Afrika
damit die kluge Geld mehr wirklich einer
Erfolg wird die offene Gesellschaft und
die Freiheit weltweit werden es uns
danken vielen Dank für Ihre Weihnachten
ja liebe Zuschauer liebe Zuschauer wenn
Sie das Gefühl hatten Frank Müller
Rosentritt hat eine Schwindel erregende
Sprechgeschwindigkeit hingelegt dann
liegt das möglicherweise daran dass er
nur zwei Minuten Redezeit hatte drei
Minuten eine mehr hat Volker klein von
der cdu/csu-fra frau Präsidentin meine
sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
im Grunde gegen Ende der Debatte kann
man jedenfalls schon mal feststellen
unser Antrag hat sein Ziel erreicht der
herannahende Termin hat Bewegung und
Aktivität ausgelöst und das war ja lange
ganz anders weil in der Tat wir haben
schon gehört als Antwort auf unsere
Kleine Anfrage dazu noch vor wenigen
Wochen überhaupt nichts zu vermelden war
aber offensichtlich
war diese Anfrage und der jetzige Termin
ein Weckruf und lieber Kollege Hofreiter
wir kritisieren doch nicht dass die
Regierung jetzt etwas tut
wir stellen allerdings etwas amüsiert
die Frage wieso weiß das Handelsblatt
die selber von einer geheimliste
sprechen jetzt bescheid dass Parlament
ist aber von der Regierung bisher noch
nicht informiert worden
aber das liegt ja quasi auf einer Linie
damit dass auch nicht alle Minister
bereits informiert worden sind sonst
hätte ja der oft ja auch gelobte
Minister Habeck bei seiner Namibia-Reise
davon gewusst aber selbst ein Minister
selbst vor dem ist das geheim gehalten
worden und das eine passt eben mit dem
anderen nicht zusammen wir müssen aber
mehr Erfolg haben und es wurde mehrfach
gesagt wir würden deutsche Interessen
hier in der Mittelpunkt stellen das muss
aber von Leuten gesagt worden sein die
den Antrag gar nicht gelesen haben weil
alleine immer vielleicht hat man dafür
dann noch Zeit alleine im Punkt 8 steht
das partnerschaftlich an gemeinsamen
Werten über nachhaltige Entwicklung in
den Projekten gesprochen werden muss
steht alles da drin und an anderer
Stelle weil ja auch noch hier verlautet
wurde Klima hätte keine Rolle gespielt
es steht drin wir brauchen nachhaltige
inklusive klimaresistente und
hochwertige
Infrastrukturinvestitionen und das ist
etwas was von afrikanischer Seite ja
auch überall verlangt wird ich habe
letzte Woche noch mit der kanarischen
Außenministerin reden können die betont
wir brauchen mehr Investitionen mehr als
alles andere Investitionen um eine sich
selbst tragende Entwicklung anzustoßen
und wenn wir dann feststellen dass wir
im Vergleich zu China bisher weniger
Angebote machen können weil es kein
level playing fehlt gibt weil die
Chinesen mit dieser Verwobenheit von
Privat und staatlichem ganz andere
Angebote machen können dann brauchten
wir ganz dringend glaube Gateway auch
aus
strategischen Überlegungen heraus diese
Initiative jetzt wird es so sein dass
sie diesen Antrag ablehnen uns ist das
Papier aber nicht so wichtig und sie ist
darum dass mit Leben erfüllt wird was
wir dort aufgeschrieben haben und
vielleicht nächstes Jahr Weihnachten
Kollegen sehr rückblickend und herzlich
danken für diese Initiative
Weihnachten wünsche nächstes Jahr müssen
wir später darüber sprechen weil ihre
Redezeit war zu Ende
und immer diese Weihnachtsgrüße wenn die
Redezeit so weit fortgeschrittenes
Zimmer schade wenn ich reinquatschen
muss ne vorher wäre ja gut
ja ein Ordnungsruf Leid der amtierenden
Bundestagspräsident Katrin Eckert
letzter Redner ist Kevin leiser von der
SPD-Fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe
Mitbürgerinnen und Mitbürger wenn sich
China verändert muss sich auch unsere
Umgang mit diesem Land verändern gefragt
sind Augenmaß und Pragmatismus China ist
und bleibt ein wichtiger Partner
aufgrund der Systemkonkurrenz dürfen wir
China aber auch in der
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit nicht das
Feld überlassen
china hat sich inzwischen zum größten
Geber der süd-süd-kooperation und zum
dreieckskorporationspartner gewandelt
mit dem Projekt der neuen Seitenstraße
fördert China aber Projekte die
vordringlich im eigenen Interesse liegen
die global Gateway Initiative der
Europäischen Union ist hierzu ein
wichtiges Gegengewicht sie zeigt das
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit in einer
regelbasierten internationalen Ordnung
auch ohne Knebelverträge und einseitige
Abhängigkeiten möglich ist
denn im Kontrast zu neuen Seitenstraße
bieten wir wie Kollegen stammer
angemerkt hatte eine Kooperation auf
Augenhöhe
insbesondere der Themenkomplex
Digitalisierung und die dazugehörige
Infrastruktur dürfen nicht zu kurz
kommen die Verbindung zu und der sichere
schnelle Informationsaustausch mit
unseren Partnern im globalen Süden ist
wichtig wir müssen dafür sorgen dass
unsere nicht in separate Wirtschafts-
Svenja Schulze sehr dankbar dass sie die
digitalpolitik des BMZ neu ausrichtet
für uns als fortschrittskoalition ist
das Internet anders als für altkanzlerin
Merkel und cdu/csu kein Neuland wir
denken Entwicklungspolitik und
digitalpolitik zusammen
Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hat in seiner
Regierung hervorgehoben und dass wir uns
global mit der Europäischen Union für
eine regelbasierte internationale
Ordnung stark machen diesem Ziel dient
auch das Engagement unserer
fortschrittskoalition zur zügigen
Umsetzung der Global Gateway Initiative
in deren Rahmen Betten wir die deutsche
Entwicklungszusammenarbeit ein in eine
europäische Entwicklungszusammenarbeit
der vorliegende Antrag zeigt jedoch die
übliche Herangehensweise der cdu/csu es
werden Allgemeinplätze wiederholt
konkrete Vorschläge sucht man vergeblich
der Antrag beinhaltet auch keine Bezüge
zur relevanten Schwerpunkten unsere
Entwicklungspolitik der Antrag bietet
keinen konstruktiven Mehrwert
Frau leikert spracheingangs von
Weihnachtswünschen und als letzter
Redner in dieser Debatte habe ich auch
einen Weihnachtswunsch dabei ich wünsche
mir zu Weihnachten dass die cdu/csu im
kommenden Jahr endlich ihre Rolle als
glaubhafte konstruktive und
staatstragende Opposition findet wir
brauchen Sie in unserer lebhaften und
wehrhaften Demokratie vielen Dank für
Ihre Aufmerksamkeit diese
Weihnachtswünsche von Kevin leiser die
waren jedenfalls innerhalb der Redezeit
sind deswegen von der Präsidentin auch
nicht moniert worden die Debatte glaube
ich werde Europäischen Union ist zu Ende
es geht um Investition in
Infrastrukturprojekte des globalen
Südens
Christkind Weihnachtsmann ist ja offen
sagen aber vorher noch dass wir die
Vorlage auf Drucksache 48 82 an die
Ausschüsse überweisen werden in der
Tagesordnung stehen und sehe dass Sie
damit einverstanden sind das ist
wunderbar
dann rufe ich jetzt damit wird dieser
Antrag in die vier Ausschüsse des
Bundestages die zuständig sind
überwiesen